que pensez-vous de charlotte de
turckheim un bing charlotte de turckheim
prenez pas cette comédienne la japonais
pas à trouver comment physiquement
j'étais un bonhomme physiquement faut
vraiment se prononcer pas terrible tiré
+ moi j'ai quand même peut-être plus
moche ni physiquement elle est pas belle
mais est excitante
ah ouais elle est pas belle mais alors
allez oui ça vous dirait tremper votre
pinceau avec elle si j'ai beau lui
rendre service
c'est un peu cheap
elle a beaucoup de charme comme fille
comme elle est pas mal oui mais enfin
disons c'est pour moi c'est pas votre
genre c'est madame non mais vraiment nul
cette meuf a rien à dire à cette pas
jouer avec ghislaine un nom à dormir
dehors
honnêtement ces moments-là bourges ou sk
répressive autoritaire la fasch être moi
je peux pas quoi tu as comme un coin où
elle est mignonne elle a du charme pour
regarder sur le plateau et elle me dit
qu'elle est très très attiré par vous
donc que lui répondez vous
du zoo qui ne s'est pas et puis pour b
j'ai vu ça pourra de réussir ce voyage
deux fois mais elle voudrait faire
l'amour à l'égout il me dit dans le
casque mais est d'accord ou pas
je la cède pas aussi facilement j'ai
juste pour nick et elle me dit qui aura
pas de sentiment du tout
sédhiou pour moi parce que je suis vieux
et puis
je m'engage et le lien souvent posée
saison d'aventuré les fans et s'attache
beaucoup
normal si mince et entend donc même là
je suis j'ai envie de vous voir c'est
normal que six jeux multi est cuit à
point
voilà c'est dit et ça va créer des
troubles dans mon village
si elle jure de ne pas s'accrocher est
ce que vous seriez prêt à lui faire
l'amour
voilà pourquoi si on pourrait quand même
que aléas sécurité que je suis en
sécurité parce que c'est iba guèye
rabais elle voudrait savoir quel est
votre spécialité et comment
[Musique]
ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu